hey guys welcome back to the evan and
katelyn podcast the podcast with not
just the questions
but also the answers
[Music]
that's a that's a big promise not all
the answers of course
just the answers to the questions of
this card game that we got from skin
deep
because each box is very expensive and i
bought a lot of them
so we need to we need to do it again
yeah
yeah when did you buy all of them i just
bought all of them because
man sometimes coming up with podcasts
ideas is really hard
and like each of these questions could
almost be
an entire podcast entire podcast so if
you need some background on the game we
have played this game on the podcast
once before
it is a very personal
and like a very deep question game and
they have different categories
play it if you really want to get to
know someone yeah if you're really bored
and quarantined
you really want to get to know the
person you're quarantined with and
there's there's various editions there's
the strangers edition co-workers
friends dating long-term and others as
in long-term relationships
and these are the ones that we have laid
out in front of us i have them actually
organized in order of like
how deep the question might get because
like strangers
co-workers friends dating long term
but at the same time i don't know maybe
the strangers one will surprise you with
some like very
personal questions that you might ask a
stranger let's see this game thing
is appropriate to ask a stranger i
wonder what the context of the stranger
one is is that like
you're just in a bar and you're like i'm
gonna
get to know somebody you know i don't
know do you want to start there
sure yeah let's do that okay
so what made you want to answer these
questions with me
oh we're recording a podcast that's
great
and we need content never-ending search
for more content oh this is interesting
what are the top five qualities you
appreciate in a person
top five qualities i appreciate in a
person
you know some of these kind of feel like
interview questions
the strangers ones are a little we'll
get some deep ones i'll i'll go if you
want
if you want to go first honesty
yes is like up there
definitely the top five uh
empathy because empathy is like broader
than kind
kindness yeah i was gonna say that raps
i was trying to think of like yeah
kindness and generosity and all these
things but a lot of that's wrapped up in
being an
empathetic like if you're empathetic
you'll probably have those other
trailing characteristics too so you're
getting a lot of mileage for
for each of your traits you're listing
yeah
what else okay okay
this is like but those who are are great
but another thing that would be nice
is vision vision
like like they they they know what like
who they are and they know where they
want to go
and they know what they want to do and
maybe i think it's also kind of like
what
who is this person yeah is it your
partner is it your friend or is it a
co-worker
like yeah is it because a business
partner because then yeah
vision but if it's like a friend it's
okay if they're just figuring stuff out
and they don't really know where they're
going
yeah that's right here i i have a
suggestion okay
are you gonna steal my top two that i
already did yeah we're
doing this cumulatively we're gonna piss
people off just like with the
personality type so they're like you
can't just like you can't just come back
to each other's questions you don't
understand we are one person
um humor humor that's great yeah i like
that
because whether it's like i can
appreciate that no matter what whatever
type of relationship you have to this
person
chill humor chill you're like i've been
chill
because it's nice to have some chill
fixed in there too you know like know
when to just like
be to let things be to like give space
and
maybe that goes into empathy also again
but maybe because it's kind of like
understandable
no no because because it it could but
someone
someone knows not chill yeah someone
could have empathy but not be chill
themselves
that's a lot so what how what are we
summarizing so far
honesty empathy empathy humor
chill and um
likes cats okay okay moving on
let's go let's go um let's go all the
way to the long term
describe the funniest moment we've
shared together
the funniest you know like moment we've
shared
honestly like this is gonna sound weird
but some of the most we've ever laughed
is like when we're just like chilling
like
on the couch and we just like get in a
giggly mood
and we just laugh and laugh and laugh
and laugh yeah like we have moments like
that i don't
necessarily know what triggers i don't
fully know what triggers it either but
like there's
there are multiple multiple like
memories in my head
of us just like cracking up and we
cannot
stop laughing and sometimes it also
leads to us
like like running in circles around the
coast
i have one i don't think we've ever
shared this
what is it there is a moment where we
were in this like
the silliest mood and no we weren't like
drinking or anything like that we were
just we're just silly weird people
and for some reason you were wearing the
pants my pants
no no did you put like grab my pants or
were you wearing them i put
them you put them on as a joke i put
your pants on and then
they're they're um they're like uh like
loose comfy pants like loungy pants and
i put them on all the way up to my
shoulders and i put my arms inside
and you're just like a little like
two-legged gremlin and this is before
that was a tick-tock trend
because people do that on tick-tock now
really this was before tick-tock existed
wow yeah and yes i just pulled them all
the way up to my shoulders and i was
just like walking around
and i was filming caitlyn and we were
laughing
so it's hard i fell over and i couldn't
get it
i felt like i injured my internal organs
yeah oh yeah the funny thing is the clip
of that does exist
only privately yeah yeah you have it
oh man that's so good it's so good that
moment popped into my
into my head as well yeah so i i can't i
don't know if i can describe the
funniest
single moment but there are a lot of
moments like that where we just are just
in a silly mood and we're just cracking
up
yeah and it doesn't have to be about
like i told a really funny joke
yeah or you told a really funny joke or
whatever
sometimes i just put on your pants and
run around like a weirdo
i think we were pre-primed though we
were already in a fairly giggly mood
yeah yeah yeah that's too often
i'm gonna turn that one over that's
that's a little bit too much
um you know what's really fun i like the
co-workers edition
i'll probably do that as my next one but
you haven't chosen in a while you go and
choose one
okay um
when was the last time this is from the
friends when was the last time you were
ashamed
of your finances
um
i mean you've been working for a long
time yeah i
started working when i was 16.
i think 15. like right before you
started working
you know i was 15 when i started working
oh oh oh yeah okay
yeah so you've been working a really
long time ashamed of my finances
and and you know i've i've been very
lucky and blessed my
my whole life and it's it's a privileged
position that
that i'm in that i can say that i
also finances haven't really ever been a
source of pride for me
you know maybe a different word is like
like
faced a challenge regarding
finances finances
i mean i didn't i didn't have a car in
college
i saved
a much of my money i think that i i've
been pretty
lucky i don't think that i mean this is
a very privileged position that to say
that i don't think i've ever been
ashamed of my finances
or let them hold me back from what i
or had them hold me back from what i
kind of where i wanted to go
yeah which is really lucky i mean i got
two really good internships in college
that paid well and
by the time i was done with college i
was like i had a job lined up
you know this is a weird thing i'm not
sure if we've told anyone this but
we actually started both of us started
our jobs
during the recession during the
recession but also
we both started our jobs before we even
graduated yeah
we we both got had internships no no
like i started working
at my job after that i was gonna go
that's why i meant like internships like
at the company that we
transitioned to well at least that's how
mine was set up it was a seamless
transition
my whole last semester of college i
worked
they just called it an internship until
i was graduated
i started working remote towards the end
of college i started
i like did remote work for the company
that i was
going to start working for when i was
that's a weird thing i don't know that
most people do that but yeah i started
working
for my next job while still in college
and i just did it remote on top of
school
yeah but it was like part-time or
something part-time right
it was just like weekends and stuff like
that yeah i just build hourly until i
moved and and you know started working
full-time
but at the same time i mean i think that
that another thing is
i like don't
i don't i mean finances are very
important
but i don't think i've ever like like
been in like
really cheap clothing standing next to
someone with very expensive clothing and
been like
i wish i had fancier clothes or a
fancier car or a fancier
this or whatever um
not that not that everyone does that but
like
i don't know as long as i have the
basics i'm happy
yeah what about you um
there have probably been times well
there have been times because i didn't
make very much money at my first job
um and there was i didn't have like
insurance or anything
so i used to have a rule of thumb where
like i wouldn't
eat out unless it was like a social
gathering so like if all my friends were
like hey we're gonna go to
wherever you know like i would come but
there was like uh i wouldn't really say
i was ashamed because part of me was
like
proud of my wilyness but i would i got
really efficient at menus
and you know we were i was living in san
antonio at the time so we went to a lot
of mexican food
and uh you can really fill up on chips
and salsa
comes for free and then i could get like
like
one single taco like one breakfast taco
for two dollars
and that would be like a very filling
meal yeah but then also my best friend i
knew she
always ordered more than she needed like
always had eyes bigger than her stomach
so she would always like
not finish half a taco and be like hey
do you want this and i'd be like
yeah i do or what if she was was
helping you out what if she ordered more
because she always knew that you wanted
a bite yeah maybe
[Laughter]
well i need to order a little bit extra
for caitlyn
yeah i don't know but ashamed really
isn't the right word i was more like
i saw it as like a challenge to figure
out how to like really
quest yeah yeah
this is another one
that's in this is a strange question to
ask friends what
is one thing you think i could change
right now to earn more income
we'll just do more videos another
sponsorship and we say
no just sleep less
and live your life a little bit less and
just work
a little more sponsorship yeah there's
so many like what's your secret fear
when it comes to finances what are your
biggest hopes all the friends ones are
finances maybe
that's kind of weird that you'd ask your
friends so much about finances
yeah because finance is the highest of
your income that's another finances
finances are pretty i don't know that's
kind of personal
not really about friends right maybe
this is close friends if you're playing
this game with him
yeah did you say you had a um was it a
strangers or a co-workers one you wanted
to ask
i just i just want to do more coworkers
i think that's interesting so much of
our life
as co-workers
okay what do you do or how do you
describe what we do to others
depends on the level if it's like
someone coming to fix
our ac we'll just say something along
the lines of like we do
advertising anyone who sees this room
that we're in now
if someone has to come into the house to
like work on the house and they see this
room
we have questions to answer yeah like
sometimes they're always like
we'll ask like so what do you guys do
or like we have a um a little thing in
our living room
that where every 10 000 subs we change
it it's like a little
light up letterboard sign and there was
someone
coming to do something on the house the
other day and he was like so i have to
ask
i saw the sign that said i think it was
like 800k subs at the time
and i saw your office what do you guys
do
and then we awkwardly are like we have a
youtube channel
and it's not that you know the only
reason we're hesitant
is because like it's kind of weird
like if someone like has been in your
house
and like knows where you live and like
you know you're just like we're just
like at our house in our pajamas like
like trying to do work drink some coffee
you know while someone's like working on
something in the house
and it's weird to then be like oh yeah
you can watch
you can watch us things do things online
yeah it's just awkward so like if it's
someone
if it's like friends or family like
we'll talk all day about what we do
if they're okay if they're okay if they
are interested
if they're interested if they ask
questions i meant like we will as in
like
we're open books about it yeah you know
um
like we're very proud of what we do but
if it's a stranger we just
prefer to give an easier answer yeah
yeah with less questions
because there can be a lot of follow-up
questions if people don't fully know how
this whole thing works because it's a
weird confusion or even if they do
yeah i'm gonna adapt this question for
friends
yeah the question is how do you think
money may change me over time
but i'll ask it again how do you think
money has changed
you and how do you think money has
changed me over time
um well i'll eat out now even if it's
not
a social gathering i think that's it
i'm still kind of a stickler about
things but i've loosened up some
i'll say a little bit of a stickler by
nature though well see for me
i'll i'll treat myself with a piece of
technology every now and then
like i bought mini computer baby
computer is that a change though
i'll feel less guilty about treating
myself to a piece of technology
like maybe like once a year yeah you
know
yeah because you used to do it you just
would feel a little bit more guilty yeah
i feel like weird
yeah i feel like guilty i'm like i
should probably save more or something
no it's a business
expense yeah it's a bit and i use i use
baby computer yeah for work
for work yeah baby computer was in the
underwater stream yeah
like having having a baby computer just
brings me joy
and that makes me happy what do you
think
makes me happy baby computer
no no no for real like okay so let me do
you okay
winning winning does make me happy
that's not what i expected
but it is kind of true i mean i do like
winning
well and it's okay it's not like winning
over other people it's not like
i i think that it's more like succeeding
succeeding caitlyn has always like
like you know wanted to get straight a's
and like do well in school
and like live responsibly and like
like i i like you want to be a good
person living a good life
and and and you you kind of like doing
things where in the end you can like be
deemed successful
yeah that's true that's true that's why
i had a hard time uh
just reading oh yeah just like reading
just for fun
yeah yeah well hobbies in general have
been
like a struggle to pick back up um
because we're so
busy for work i was going to say that's
why i like was very hesitant to start
playing minecraft
oh yeah which i love now yeah
because now we you know
kind of well i like understand it more
but in the beginning i was like there's
no like
levels you know like play through this
level and be the boss and then play
through this level and beat a boss like
there's no goals
what oh okay i'll one more thing
creating and winning those are two
things that like yeah
make you happy i'm gonna
i mean i i i would say um for you
definitely the like i mean i think you
like creating and winning also
um one thing i will add and this is more
of a
like if this is present we are not happy
but the lack of it does make us happy is
like
uh the removal of time
pressure i was gonna say freedom for me
yeah freedom freedom too those are very
related to us yeah
freedom freedom yeah
i'm most happy when i can just like when
there's when i can just do whatever i
want
and we say that we mean that like within
the context
of our work yeah because like
it's not frequent that we're just like
i'm just gonna
uh count my pencils today
no but like i like i i'm
there's no real word for it so i'm going
to use like a dumb word that i don't
like but like i'm a little bit of a free
spirit
yeah you are i don't like i don't like
that word i don't like that description
but i don't know what else to say
for that but i like flitting around from
task to task i like like
you know doing some game uploads and
then like
you know researching some games and then
like tinkering in the shop
and then like like i do like doing one
big
like work thing per day in a way whether
it's
record a podcast play a game uh record a
little bit of the next project or plan
and
some big element of the next thing so i
kind of like
one like chunk
of the day to be around something like
big and focused that i can say yes
win progress but then around that i just
like to like
we like things to be mixed up and i
think the hard thing is like when we're
under a lot of time pressure for example
um because we've over scheduled
ourselves and we have too many
like commitments to sponsors too close
to each other then
every single day the entire day is
filming and it has to be filming because
if it's not filming the video won't be
done
we haven't been in that situation in a
bit but
something like that you don't have the
freedom to
say like okay i'm going to
film for a couple hours today but
then i just want to like go through some
emails because the inbox has been
bothering me and
then i'm going to like research some
games that we might want to play or you
know whatever it is yeah
man i just got like while you're
chatting i was listening to you but then
i was also like
throwing away all of the friends cards
about money
like yeah there's a lot i know that like
money is an important
part of personal life
but i guess i just haven't talked about
money issues with like
with friends anyone really like
like maybe my parents yeah but not even
much with like my brother or sister
yeah like i don't really talk about
money with like anyone maybe that's the
purpose of these cards
maybe you do because yeah money is so
happy very complicated thing
but it's also not the most exciting to
talk about with you because
we i guess that's why i guess that's why
it's in friends and not dating
it's not in the long term maybe it
should be in dating maybe it should be
about
you know that is like one thing that
like
is a unique barrier to overcome when you
start dating
like combining finances and figuring
that out like i know that when
when we started dating um we had a
spreadsheet
that i had to make up because you felt
guilty about money issues i wanted to
make sure i was con well it wasn't when
we started dating it was when we started
living living together yeah
i want to make sure i was contributing
enough because my income was
significantly less than yours
and then you're like okay so we need to
like you know split all the groceries
and split all of this and
do the finances that's one moment when i
felt guilty about finances actually
when i was well you know like as an
engineer
was making more than than you i felt
guilty that i was making more than you
mm-hmm and i felt like if i
like wanted to go out you would want to
do half
and i just wanted to pay for it and
then i'd feel like i'm forcing you to
spend your money
that's interesting yeah i don't think
i've ever said that
i think i like kind of knew yeah but i
felt like
like i had to restrain myself a little
bit yeah in a way
yeah because i wanted you to feel like
you were contributing just as much and
and everything
so i did like hold back yeah that's
interesting
i think of it once we bought the house
together i think
we did buy a house together before we
were married
not that i'd fully recommend that to
everyone oh yeah and you like
co-signed on my car yeah so like
it didn't take long for us to just be
like i mean we knew we knew that we were
gonna get married
before we moved in together i wanted to
feel like i was
contributing okay i have a question for
you
yes this is fun i i have a lot of fun
with this okay go for it
if i had to give up one of my senses
which one do you think i'd choose and
why
not sight
so not touch
not cider touch my guess would be
smell yeah i mean they say that smell
does affect your taste but i'd rather
taste than the smell
yeah i'd rather just have things taste a
little
less good which would be sad but then at
least i'd eat healthy because it'd be
like well might as well eat the celery
well you'd have to lose your your
sense of smell and taste to fully lose
it yeah
but i'll say smell yeah yeah because
hearing sight touch yeah those are the
key yeah you know
i'll lose my sixth sense and just not
see ghosts anymore oh okay yeah
i've already lost most of my sense of
balance so yeah that's true
okay what do you think for me probably
the same yeah
yeah sorry this is a weird this is a
weird question
what's unique about my eyes caitlyn
stare
into my eyes hmm
do you remember that one time we were
like out of schlotsky
and it was really really weirdos like it
was too weirdo it was really
there's really really bright sunlight
coming in in a way that it like
really shined on both of our eyeballs
yeah like the eyeballs
yeah and we just spent some time like
really staring into each other's eyes
because most of the time your eyes are
kind of like shadowed and you don't get
the full
and we both have brown eyes you know
yeah it's like it seems like it's boring
but in my eyes if you look there's like
kind of goldy
like goldish and kind of greenish right
yeah you have like like an outer ring
that's a different color but i guess
you know maybe that's the case with a
lot of people and we just never
look at their eyes that closely look at
their eyes that closely
okay you have really nice eyelashes also
you have the best eyelashes i think oh
thank you yes i think
you have very expressive eyes like
and you always kind of look like you're
like plotting something
well mischievous eyes
and that's one thing that's unique about
your eyes your eyes are really cute
that's what's really oh thank you
okay what was that that was that in the
dating one that was in the dating yeah
that's just that's just an excuse to
look at each other's eyes yeah but i do
think of that time at schlozki's where
we just stared at each other i was
during her
eyeballs yeah during the dating phase
what's one thing that we could do to
improve our working relationship
well probably just not work as much
um i'll try to give like a serious
answer
i think that that we've done so much
already to improve our working
relationship we've talked about it
multiple times on
the podcast how we like communicate so
much and um
one thing that we have done a lot more i
think in the last year
is uh
or i guess maybe not just in the last
year but over time we've kind of fallen
into like
there are some tasks that are like
primarily caitlyn tasks
some things that are primarily evan but
i think we've added to the things that
both of us can do like
all gaming channel stuff used to be you
and like now i've taken on a lot of it
to help balance
it um but i'm trying to think of like
like if there are pain points i think
the biggest thing
that we've done recently and like you
said the biggest thing is to reduce
the amount we work because that you know
the more we have on our schedule
like we if something's on our schedule
we've committed to something we're going
to do it
that's just like kind of who we are
we've said that before um
and the only way to cut back on work is
just to not commit to it in the first
place which takes a lot of
forth you know foresight into
how much is reasonable and how much you
can commit to while
maintaining yeah like balance and i
think that since we've gotten better at
that
the main thing we've been improving is
like you know yesterday
we thought that we were going to stream
and record
two ads and then we're like no no let's
not set that expectation let's only set
the expectation that we're just gonna
stream
and do all the miscellaneous to-do's
that we have and we changed that in
advance
and we had a much better day because of
it yeah
because either way we weren't gonna have
time to film those two ads no
it wasn't gonna happen so by changing
our expectation beforehand
we weren't like disappointed but
setting reasonable expectations that's
that's a good way to improve our working
relationship
yeah but we already we already do that
we already do that
yeah i don't think that like there's
there isn't anything that i've thought
that i haven't mentioned to you because
if i have a thought to improve it i
mentioned it to you right away
and then we just let's just do it try it
yeah
yeah i think that's why this is hard we
just we've already done
everything that we've thought of to do
we've done we've implemented already
yeah there's no reason for either of us
to like hold on to
something because we're embarrassed yeah
it's like we'll say like it kind of
annoyed me a little bit when you
did that and i wrote oh wow thanks for
telling me i'm sorry
i won't do that again you know thanks
yeah or like hey could you
help me out with this yeah that's like
i'm feeling a little overwhelmed
overwhelmed
yeah or like
hey i think we should reorganize our
to-do list in this way that would help
me out oh okay cool let's do it and we
just yeah we just change things we just
do it in the moment yeah
what do you think your biggest my
biggest challenge at work is right now
working too much yeah there's a lot of
these that are like a little bit too
easy for us
oh i have a going this is in the long
term relationships
do your best impression of me when i'm
angry
okay uh should i go first do you wanna
go first you go first
um
it's tough because the main way i know
you're angry
isn't because you express it it's
because you
you don't it's a lack of what you do you
don't communicate you're more silent
um you're you're
shorter with me a little bit
but like there isn't like there's not
like an impression there isn't like i
like
you you don't you don't like get angry
at me you're just angry i get
yeah i get quiet and you get quiet you
go into dark caitlyn mode
and you you like kind of sulk
but not for very long no no no no not
very very long we usually hug it out
like
a little bit later than like usually
minutes usually minutes
maybe an hour yeah
i'm gonna try to think well it also
doesn't have to be angry at each other
okay okay yeah because like there's
definitely thing you can do an
impression of me when i'm angry
at a project because then i get like i
get verbally upset
i think that's more interesting so
here's evan
i can't i just can't right now i just
i'm gonna need a minute i'm just gonna
need
i'm just i just need to rethink things
i'm just gonna
we'll have to redo it i'm just gonna
need a minute
i just need some space i just need some
space just
kidding like just work on the edit for a
little bit
i'll let you know when i'm ready uh oh
oh i i have yours now and you're like
because like when we're angry at each
other we don't we don't get any
we get angry but we don't ever take it
out on each other no
when we express anger it's towards other
things yeah and i'll do
my impression of caitlyn i can't believe
that they would be so irresponsible they
didn't even think
about like how that affect us you know
like i can't believe they don't have
their poop together
my gosh how unprofessional of them
[Music]
i get mad people are not responsible
or considerate like can they not respect
what we are doing here
like do they not understand how much
like we we we did not we did everything
that we said
and we were on time with everything we
did everything like
and then they just do this full company
with a full set of resources
i'm like how come how come it's faster
for us to
knock this out than for them that's not
fair how can they even manage
how can they even run when they can't
even do this
that's so true i get i get mad when
companies like don't have their act
together
and it results in us having to waste our
time yeah that's when you get the most
angry or like making us stressed out
because all of a sudden we have to
change everything in rush yeah
oh that's so true you hit the nail on
the head live yeah
that was fun that was fun what was your
most embarrassing experience this is
from the stranger pile
um the most embarrassing experience i'm
gonna try to think of mine too
i know one okay i think i've already
told this briefly
maybe i haven't it's like i don't know i
i don't know if it's
my most embarrassing but it's the one
that pops into my head first
but i know my parents are gonna be
listening to this
but in fifth grade i was in a drama
class you've heard the story
and we had to make write a commercial
like a made-up commercial and perform it
in front of class
and my dad helped me write one for nine
lives cat food
and you know looking back it was a
brilliant commercial brilliant
it was good like i i do stand by it now
but
the humor was maybe a little dry for my
fellow fifth graders
and i got up and i performed that entire
thing
to just dead silence no no plotted
afterwards
no there was just no reaction at all and
i had a lot of jokes in it you know if i
hadn't had jokes in it and i was just
like
here are the benefits of this product
and here's why you should buy it
then it's fine but it was you know there
it all built up to this big punch line
at the end and there were many
like little tiny jokes throughout and by
dry i mean like it's like kind of like
uh
like it's like delivered with a straight
face yeah yeah yeah you know so it was
like this whole thing about like
you know if your cat is acting weird and
doing all this
stuff uh then maybe you should
put on your glasses and stop feeding
them soap
and start feeding them nine lives
which is a real product yeah this is a
real product i think we had to pick a
real product yeah
but then there was like a secondary
twist where like and your dad gave you
the thumbs up he was like yeah that's
great
yeah there's a secondary twist where you
like real well i
where i the character realized because i
hadn't been wearing my glasses i was
also feeding it to my dog and then like
the dog meows and i props i had like my
beanie babies as props
and it was so thought out and i
performed this thing
and it was just dead faces from my
entire class and i was so embarrassed by
the end of it that i you know when you
start getting hot and flustered yeah i
kind of started like tearing up a little
bit
and then i was like everyone can see me
tearing up no no no
i got even more no no and then it got so
worse and i was
i so like you led me astray
you told me this was gold
it was good though it was a good it was
a good commercial and look at me now
look at me now i do sponsored reads all
the time and i think we make them pretty
funny
we do and i channel that same energy
that humor has gotten like more and more
acceptable and like what like widely
understood
you know it was also like 10 year olds
the 10 year old still might not get it
oh hi doobie you want to hang out during
the podcast it's the most embarrassed
i've been i think that i just strongly
strongly repress every time that's
happened
to the point where like that there's a
weird thing to like admit
but i have forgotten much of my life
like you know the good and the bad
honestly like you know
i've traveled a whole bunch and i've you
know in in my younger years i've
forgotten like
so many places we've traveled because we
know my family lived overseas we
traveled a whole bunch and
in some booths you weren't even that
young my parents are like yeah we've
been there and i'm like what i don't
remember that and they're like you were
10.
how do you not remember well like i i
i'll
admit that i am a fairly forgetful
person there's a lot that i
really remember like i really remember
the past like
since we started dating 10 years so
since we started
it's crazy we've been like not quite not
10 years but like
we started dating in 2011 though nine
years so
all of that stands out as like core
pieces in my head and stuff but i just
forget a lot and if i want to forget
something
i forget it faster
there's no like school presentation
first day at work stumbles
i'm sure there is i know i
i remember like you know i i know the
feeling that you get where you get that
hot flash
and you're like oh my gosh i just need
to like hide into a hole
and never come out ever again i've
gotten that multiple multiple times and
then i just like
suppress it well here i have another
story to make up for it okay this is
this one was less embarrassing i mean
you know oh i'll say like there's
multiple times where i like slipped and
fell and
felt embarrassed in front of other
people or something like that like
i was wearing my cheap like one dollar
old navy flip-flops that are like
a slick piece of plastic on both sides
and
are you saying he's taking my story no
no i've done it too okay because i was
about to say another one of my like
this one wasn't as bad because i didn't
necessarily
know the people who saw it happen yeah
but it's still pretty embarrassing
old navy used to sell these platform
shoes that were like a couple bucks and
they were entirely made out of foam
like the entire thing was just a block
of foam
which i don't know how you call that
shoes
i had like a bright orange pair and a
bright green pair and i
wore them to school one on each foot
no no no not that crazy i wore them to
school and at the front of our school we
had like a school store
and so it was always popping it was
popping so many kids
everyone was at the school store it had
been raining i walked in i had the tile
i immediately like comically slipped
because
those shoes just soaked in the water
because there are sponges
i slipped my feet went straight up into
the air and i fell on my back
i think i had my backpack on so didn't
hurt too much only my pride
yeah yeah i mean i remember some injury
stories like once i was uh
playing some ball game i don't know what
it was but i was running backwards to
get the ball
might have been football might have been
some other ball
anyways i i left the field
um and i was like running backwards to
catch it you know
and then i turned and
right as i turned i turned into a
basketball pole
oh and i hit right here thankfully it
didn't hit my eye or anything but it hit
like like right there
boom and i had like a big swollen lump
over my eye and i felt kind of
embarrassed about that but also i think
my brother i was so
in pain i was so in pain i don't think i
was that embarrassed
because i was like ow that hurts
and that's the main thought that i had i
don't really remember too many
embarrassing moments
i will say i felt a strange mix of
embarrassment
and other feelings when i got caught
in high school messing with the server
and playing
halo and i got called out in front of
the whole class
was it embarrassment or pride a little
bit
yeah that was fun
man halo back then oh so good okay
okay this is an easy one for you but i'm
curious about for me
no no yeah not that one
i'll tell you why later all right um do
your best impression of me when i'm
happy
just a silence the impression ones are
kind of weird
what about me how do you how do you do
an impression of you when i'm happy
okay part of this is visual so i'm sorry
if you're not uh watching the podcast
hi hi i love you i love you
that's you do that too i know that's
that's our impression of what we're
happy
we just get really close to each other
and look at each other lovingly and say
hi
no i'll do this because like i think
that one thing that we do
that is nice when we're happy my
impression of us when we're happy is
like
hey you know what we're doing really
good i'm happy
this is nice you know it's like we're we
we created the situation for ourselves
and i just wanted to acknowledge that
we're doing really well and we're really
happy
and that's nice we do do that we like
sometimes
confirm it to each other we affirm it to
each other and that's really nice i like
that
and then we'll say i wonder why we're so
happy right now it's probably because of
blank blank blank probably because we
don't have any crazy deadlines
yeah at this moment you know i think
that like you know we've changed the
direction
of what we're doing and pivoted in
really nice ways i really want to
acknowledge that we've
we've made that change and that's really
nice yeah yeah
we're weird
but we do do that i like it i like it we
do
um what is my greatest talent that i
could utilize more of
the from the co-workers edition your
greatest talent that you could utilize
more of huh
i think you have a lot of skills that
we're trying to figure out
how to use them in projects and one
example is the underwater live stream
yeah and like another kind of smaller
example
was like the recent like painting denim
jackets with
uh air blaster yeah lots of things that
you want to do more of that
pressure systems and
like technology like you have a lot of
skills from your work life i want to
like hook up sensors to something for
some reason
and record data i want to record some
data there you go see
we don't know exactly how to like apply
some of these skills
but i feel like you have a lot of that
would make us our content stand out more
yeah we do have like the underwater
stream like that knowledge in my head
like the complexity of what you put
together is like
um it's it's so complex that most people
won't do it you know what i mean yeah
and you have the ability to
do a lot of stuff that is a lot more
complex
one thing that i i want to do with with
you
and we have some plans for it but do
more drawing
because you're really good at drawing
and we can incorporate some of that into
our projects in certain ways
i would do more bob ross paintings it's
not really the same yeah
i have an idea though yeah for drawing
and resin
mixing them um is it a good layered it
is layered
i want to do that i do want to do that i
want to do that like for sure that would
be cool
multiple mediums like all mixed yeah i
do like when i get to be a little
artistic like
when i drew got to draw like space jube
for
um the burnt wood art or like uh
because that is a rare talent that you
have you're really good at drawing oh
thank you baby
request drawings on streams those are
not my
artistic peak but they're fun i think
another thing that i could do a little
more of besides bringing more of my
engineering
knowledge actually this is one thing i
do i do this
a decent amount i like analyze the big
picture of things a lot
i feel like you see how we like see how
we can keep on improving and doing other
things
yeah i feel like you already do that
yeah though all right
what what category should we do next
let's do a dating
what do you think my biggest conflict
is right now i think we've oh in in
dating in our relationship
let's say sometimes we wonder like
if if we freed up more free time
oh yeah oh yeah we're like what
would we do that phil
feels fulfilling yeah
still that is not related to work yes
that we would enjoy doing because we've
just been like pushing so hard
and it's kind of extra hard right now
because of like you know the state of
the world
yeah you know we can't like but even
ignoring that
i mean i think that like you know
besides the the easy answers of like
let's go on vacation
of course that sounds nice yeah but like
we're not realistically gonna go on
vacations like every weekend
yeah yeah but we were like if we had
weekends again
how would we fill that time yeah and
it's just so foreign now to think of
having all that
extra i want to work less so that we
have weekends so we can figure out how
to fill them
because it's kind of like you almost
need that time
to figure out what you want to fill that
time with yeah
you know because like when you're just
hustling along you have a big to-do list
and you have a ton of things that you
already have decided that you're going
to do it's hard to like
think of other things to do yeah
and like i think that our default things
of like me playing more video games
or you reading is don't want to do that
for like a whole weekend
no no but like this is the thing that is
an escape from everything
you know so that's not an addition that
we need to decide on that's like an
escape hatch we can take
yeah and i think that's why we can do
those because
that's not like a decision like you know
we're decisioned out and we have all
this stuff that we already have on our
plate
so like reading or playing games is an
escape hatch from that instead of like
us having to sit down and brainstorm and
decide i wanna
learn pottery i guess that would be like
a video
might be a video yeah yeah i was just
trying to think of a hobby that we don't
currently
yeah so many hobbies that normal people
have are video ideas for us
[Laughter]
yeah that's an interesting one
oh we're we're just going to be like
putting some of the like what when you
look at me what do you see
a handsome devil with a nice beard
a a
wholesome person i love it very much
thank you
that you're gonna say a cat because i'm
wearing cat ears and i got a cat shirt
i see cat
when you dream of our future what are
the first three things you see
i i have one in my head
i have two in my head
i see a
a bigger house with more space more
workshops spays more office space
i see a hot tub yes i really want i
really want like a nice outdoor space
because like we were just saying like
you know i think a great thing to do if
you have extra time
is like if you have a nice outdoor space
just hang out outside
yeah just be outside so i would really
like a hot tub
um i i don't know that's only two things
and they're mostly
house related i see us being um
at some point like
eventually less stressed
about content and just putting things
out at a chiller pace
and being cool with that i also see a
more
dedicated art space
right that'd be cool where you have all
of your pens and markers and paints and
watercolors and
brushes and and all of that because i
think right now all of our art stuff
gets put away
every time it's hard to like you know
work on a project and put it out and
take it out and you know it's like we
don't have a dedicated
space for just art projects and i think
that if it was set up if we were like oh
well we have an hour
what do we want to do i think that it
might strike us that we might want to
just do some art
yeah i don't know yeah we might and
that's a luxury
for us to have in the future but like i
think that it's worth
trying you know and maybe we just have
like a different
part of our workshop that's for art we
probably would
have it outfitted with like filming
lights
yeah in case because if we're doing a
bob ross video
it'd be cool to do it in the art room
yeah the future art room
another thing is like i do just keep on
seeing us expanding with more things
like it's always been a dream of mine to
have
a workshop that has everything for
everything
you know like well we're going to get a
laser cutter i know
eventually in the future where i i still
want like a little bit of metal working
you know like a forge and stuff just
because it's fun to like
turn metal into taffy and stretch it
around and
do that stuff like we'll only do it once
or twice a year
but i still want it um
so those are my thoughts and the same
things yeah
let's put that up what do you value more
in a person
their intention or their action
there's two ways to look at that this
one way
is okay so let's say let's say you're
saying you value their
intention more i think that applies if
someone is like
i am trying to make a good change in the
world and they go out and they do some
action
and maybe it fails in that case it's
like well your intention was there and
you tried
but i think the flip side is
um if they're like i want to do a good
change in the world
and then they never try anything
then the intention doesn't really matter
so much so i think a lot of it comes
down to like are they attempting any
sort of action
i think that i i'll say action
yeah i mean i think like
i feel like no matter what it's
important to take some
sort of action i do think action like in
general
action is more important
but there are some cases where it's like
you you intend to do something
you try and you fail but like in a way
action always implies
intent because no one acts without an
intent
so action has both intent is just
intent that's a good point you know yeah
so so of course action
yeah yeah yeah that's a good point
what do you think i have yet to learn
about relationships
i think that's i think that's a tough
question to ask someone you've been
married to for so long
yeah i think when you're dating because
i think that this is this is one thing
that a lot of people do in dating
situations it's like when you're dating
you kind of like hold some cards
you like don't reveal your full thing
well and for us that wasn't really a
thing because we had been
good friends for five years before we
even started dating so like we
were already out we had discussed
relationships in depth
as friends yeah we're like is this
normal in a relationship is this
like what what do you what would you do
in this situation yeah so we've
discussed relationships a ton
um what is the first thing you noticed
about me that interest you
when when we were like um i think it's
like when we first met
maybe i mean this is this might
sound a little bit like okay there's two
there's two aspects of it because like
of course when you
visually see someone what do you first
notice i noticed how beautiful you were
you're so beautiful and so cute and then
the second thing that i noticed is like
you had like a very
like good vibe energy about you
you were just like like positive and
like
good you just had goodness surrounding
you
i think the first thing i noticed about
you and maybe it's because like it was
very opposite to how i
was feeling but you know i'm a little
bit of a shy person
sometimes especially like in new
situations
and i like am sometimes kind of awkward
about
like getting to know new people in class
you know like i would my tendency might
just be to kind of like keep to myself a
little bit more
and i just noticed that you were like so
friendly
and so open and very
easy to talk to and you didn't make me
feel intimidated
coming up to you whereas like i think
most people like i was intimidated
coming up to most people
and like there was just like
an ease and an openness about you that
that made you not scary for me to come
like talk to i don't know you're just
very welcoming and
like i like that yeah thank you
yeah is that why you were able to ask me
to be your ballroom dance partner
probably
i like that thank you
um
do your best impression of me when i'm
overwhelmed or did we decide not to do
impressions anymore we can do them if
they're funny it's kind of the same one
as when you're
you were angry i just need a moment
just give me like five minutes in the
garage i think when when you're
overwhelmed
you just get like really
you just double down on your like work
yeah
and you just like you just like focus
100 you don't talk too much
and when you when you're overwhelmed the
only the main movement when you're
overwhelmed is when you're editing
and you just get in the zone and i know
to just like
give you space but then check in every
now and then to see if you need a new
like
like and i like mainly i'll just like
get you to stand up and move around
every now and then like all right
standing break let's like
shake the caitlyn out by literally be
just coming over and like
like picking me up out of my chair give
me a hug
let's get you to stretch and move a
little bit yeah
yeah there's there's
so many impressions do your impressive
when we're excited
do your best impression of me when i'm
hung really hungry
do we need to do this can we end the
stream
can you hurry that up oh i thought you
were gonna go because i actually say
this
caitlyn hungry caitlyn hungry great on
hunger
sorry are you getting embarrassed no i'm
just i'm just getting sweaty
that's funny you don't get upset when
you're hungry
this is this is you when you're hungry
actually it's it's very different i
really get upset but i do get
bothered urgent things just get more
urgent
this is you okay i'm on the couch
i don't i don't know i'm just i'm
feeling like really tired like super
drained so
drained then i asked have you been
drinking water yeah
have you was last time you ate anything
oh yeah i might be really hungry
i just get yeah my energy drops you just
drop energy
my energy just like i run out of steam
and you sometimes don't like aren't able
to identify it
but then like you eat and you feel
better i feel so much better after
eating
yeah okay oh this very interesting one
this is from the friends category but
this this might lead to an interesting
conversation
oh and we might need to um uh start
wrapping it up soon oh my gosh the time
flies myself
i just want to keep on doing this it's
fun this is so much fun
when was our toughest moment together
oh it's climbing tongariro count
oh my gosh that took some willpower
tongariro we've talked about it before
but we we've got a full podcast on it
we have a full podcast on it don't we
i'm pretty sure we definitely talked
about it like
a decent amount in one podcast but yeah
we we did we went for a
12 hour hike that we were not ready for
it was a 10 it was like a 10-hour hike
in new zealand
that we thought we could tell up and
down a mountain
up and down like like a full
crater system it took us 10 hours
i was wearing skinny jeans we were not
prepared it was
very hard
other tough moments is like around
content creation
like when we were just so overwhelmed
and we were slogging and we had been
slogging for so long
remember like that all-nighter you you
pulled to to pull off the
edit for the collab with bob yeah the
ping pong table that was
rough it was like late night after
all-nighter after all-nighter it was
just like
but you know what i think was actually
harder than like some of the
um slogs of uh
like when we really got in the weeds
with the channel
which like you know it's been a while
since those happened but
i think with those it was more like well
you know at least we're still doing
something we like we just need to learn
what our limits are so we don't like get
ourselves in a bind where we have to
pull all nighters in the future because
a lot of it was like learning process
yeah you know we have it's been a long
time
figuring out like what we can handle but
i think
a harder period is before you
quit your job before i before either of
us like had even thought about starting
the channel
and you were working that really hard
job where you had to
work weekends and you were working like
12 hours a day and
you just really did not like it
i think that in some ways is a harder
thing because
it felt more out of our control yeah i
did like
we've talked about it some ourselves but
i don't think i've talked about on the
podcast but
i did always feel like the pressure to
figure out
my long-term career and like you know i
wasn't happy
fully with where i was at
before i quit and figured this out and i
did feel like the weight
of forever
doing that forever on my shoulders and
not fully being happy with it yeah i
feel like that was a
that was a it's interesting because that
wasn't like a tough moment
but it was like a tough period period
and
burden and and stuff like that and i
think like we realized it more after
even yeah like looking back on that as a
whole
it's like because in the moment it's
just kind of like
well just you know just we're figuring
stuff out but then looking back it was
like oh
that was not the best well guys we we we
barely it seems crazy but we've still
barely scratched the surface of these
decks oh my gosh i know oh caitlyn what
they released another deck what's the
thing it's called the amusing edition
oh is that like things that will lead to
funny stuff if i was a texture what
would i be
and why we have to get it and i lost all
of my memory and explain the concept of
love to me
do you know what your texture would be
what's that beard
beard yours would be
fur
my texture is jube i like this one too
dance the story of your childhood
okay we i think we might have to get
order that pack
i'm excited i'm excited more and even
more incentive for
watching the podcast podcast the amusing
edition
that'll be fun that'll be really fun all
right guys well um
before we we wrap things up it's time
for thing of the week
all righty kalyn what's one thing that i
need
more of in my life definitely not knives
today's thing of the week is a knife
it's but it says it's a special knife
made by a fellow youtuber
um the the people over at physics
anonymous they uh send this over to us
as a preview of their kickstarter so
this is something that not many people
other than we have so we feel pretty
lucky um it's a replaceable blade
utility knife i know that there's
a lot of them out there but i just love
looking at all the different designs
i i think it's kind of i like the
snapback i like the snapback i think
it's a little bit of a joke
of like all the makers designing their
own knives and releasing them on
kickstarter
it's not something that i haven't
considered we may or may not have some
prototypes
we i we do have some prototypes um you
know there's just a lot of logistical
aspects of like don't take that as like
uh like we're trying to tease that
something's no no no no no no no no it's
just
like all the makers everyone's got ideas
for the best knife
yeah this is a cool one though yeah
because i i i definitely like the
replaceableness of it
i always like replaceable blade knives i
do like that it locks
um that's a good feature but yeah i'm
always like thinking about what's the
uh what's the way to get like the
smallest knife possible with a
replaceable blade
um that is safe for in your pocket and
all of that and it's just interesting to
see other people's attempts so
the kickstarter is live now if you want
to check it out the link will be in the
description
and my thing of the week is a show we've
been watching
on netflix it is called the umbrella
academy
we are about halfway through season two
there's only two seasons right now but
it's been so enjoyable it's good yo
it's like um if you
mixed a little bit of i mean
i mean my impression of it in the very
beginning was like
is it this is kind of like a combination
of like
uh x-men and knives out because there's
like some murder mystery and there's
like some
mysterious superpower kind of things but
i don't really feel like that
quite anymore because like in the x-men
universe
there's just like mutants running around
all over the place this has a lot of
time travel a lot of very interesting
characters
very interesting characters even like
minor characters they put a lot of
detail
in them to make them no interesting and
not just generic flat
and non-complicated everyone is very
complicated which i love
because they're all real the show has
like a
like it really uses music well
yeah um like and oh and an interesting
thing one of my
favorite bands from high school my
chemical romance
uh the lead singer gerard way is the
producer and i think he wrote the
original comic
yeah the umbrella academy which the show
is based on and so i was like
ah that's so cool it's a really good
show but
really good i also think that like
honestly
one thing that is a little bit of a
deterrent for me really getting into
some
more serious shows like this is when
they're too serious and they're just
depressing and they're too old
all the time and they're just all
emotionally heavy this one does have
those
good like breaks that like
there's a lot of humor added to it
there's humor and there's like little
elements where like you know like
something crazy is happening maybe
even just like you know sad but then
they're playing like
cheery jolly music over it and that yeah
like contrast and everything
and like it's a it's a rich show and i
think that i think that's nice but it's
also balanced with
the humor and the light-heartedness yeah
it's not too emotionally
heavy but it still has like very
interesting
drama and intrigue it's just that it's
balanced with like comedy and action
and mystery and all this stuff yeah so
that's fun
it's a really good show all right well
that that that hour passed by
faster than i could have ever imagined
wow i hope you guys
enjoyed the show and make sure as always
to leave a five star review so we can
trick people into listening to something
that they
don't know what it is and that's that's
the
prank of evan and katelyn podcast
bye bye guys